at the end of elden ring we come across
a mysterious and controversial figure
our final test and fight at first
appears to be with ratagon of the golden
order the other side of queen america
and a figure foretold throughout the
game with the very first moments of the
game introducing marika and ratagan
hammering away at the elden ring it
would be fitting for the game to end
with them as well but it does not for
when we defeat radagon the elden ring at
his core fades and blackness oozes out
from this mire arises an arm that
swallows the red-haired hero into the
depths and then out comes the amorphous
celestial slug of purple and gold the
true final boss of the game the elden
beast
as we delve into what little lore there
is about this beast we may find more
questions than answers what i discussed
about the elden beast in my outer gods
video concerning it and the greater will
covered much of the explicit in-game
references to it and speaking of my
other videos feel free to subscribe to
the channel to keep up to date with all
of my lore and elden rain content
despite it being the final boss the
elden beast is hardly mentioned or
referenced before the fight the only
explicit reference that i know of comes
from the elden stars incantation found
in the deep root depths below the
archery it reads it is said that long
ago the greater will sent a golden star
bearing a beast into the lands between
which would later become the elden ring
from this and what we will see later we
learn that the elden beast is basically
a guard dog for the greater will the
outer god at the head of the golden
order and it serves to enact the greater
wills plans and machinations in the
lands between the greater will sent the
elden beast and eldon ring to the lands
between at some point long ago the elden
beast was meant to ensure that the elden
ring operated according to the crater
will's desires
after we fight and defeat the beast we
obtain its elden remembrance which gives
us slightly more insight describing the
creature as the vassal beast of the
greater will and the living incarnation
of the concept of order
a vassal is a person or country in a
subordinate position to another a vassal
state is under the control of another
country and a vassal individual could be
for instance a knight who serves a king
and receives certain privileges such as
land
so in understanding the elden beast as a
vassal to the greater will it is a beast
of servitude and being a beast likely
doesn't get any reward or privilege from
this we see that it acts completely at
the behest of the greater will we also
learn from the remembrance that it
serves an important metaphysical role in
the lands between it is not just the
guard dog of the ring it is also the
living incarnation of the concept of
order if something is an incarnation it
is a thing or concept embodied in flesh
or matter coming from the latin in
carnarei with in being into and karo or
karne being flesh or meat incarnation
being literally translated into flesh it
is a word often used in religious
contexts such as in christianity where
jesus is referred to as god incarnate or
made flesh on the earth with the elden
beast as order incarnate we see a
parallel from a real world religion to
the in-game religion of the greater will
which is founded in and on order it is
called the golden order after all
so the elden beast is a watchdog of the
elden ring and it is also the embodied
manifestation of order in the world it
serves as some kind of anchor point if
we think of order as something which
permeates the land though with the state
that we find the lands between in it
seems that the permeating order is not
achieving much net good this raises
another question to be asked how does
our understanding of order and the elden
beast change when we consider the
position of the greater will especially
in context of such a destroyed world in
the round table hold anya tries to
convince us that the greater will
has not abandoned the realm
nor the life that inhabits it
but i don't think this is actually the
case
in promotional material for the game
that is still up on bandai namco's site
the war that preceded the events of the
game the shattering is called quote a
war that meant abandonment by the
greater will and the golden order is
described as quote broken
but before you get on my case that
promotional material may not necessarily
be canon we can look in game for
evidence as well in game after the
player is spurned by the erd tree the
two fingers are still and silent and
they remain that way for the rest of the
game
enya says that they are in communication
with the greater will about thousands
if not tens of thousands of moons must
first pass
sounds like quite a while to wait before
we can make a judgment in all likelihood
the greater will has cut off contact
with the fingers and we know the fingers
are also referred to as vassals just
like the elden beast so if the greater
will isn't talking to the fingers it
likely isn't talking to the big blob
either with such an abandonment where
does that leave the elden beast the
guard dog without a master the elden
beast is both without guidance from the
greater will and suffering from the
breaking of the golden order in another
confirmation of that earlier promo
material when we fight the elden beast
we can notice cracks on its belly before
we land a single blow now we might be
able to say that this is from our fight
with ratagon but i think it's a
reasonable conclusion that the elden
beast being an incarnation of order
would bear the mark of the order being
broken
we do also know from the mending rune of
perfect order that the current golden
order contains imperfection that may not
be a direct reference to this breaking
but all of this seems connected to me in
a way that lets us say fairly
uncontroversially that the golden order
is indeed in a broken state during the
events of the game
plus to not forget the most obvious
point the elden ring was shattered the
elden beast bears close connection to
the ring so it bearing a mark of the
shattering makes sense so painting the
fullest picture we can of the context
around the elden beast shows us that it
is a now abandoned vassal of the greater
will which exists to protect the elden
ring the shattering and breaking of the
golden order has left it broken as well
and that is how we find it in the final
fight of the game
its environment is a mirror of itself a
contrast of celestial bodies
foregrounded by the golden light of many
in her tree perhaps these are herd trees
of other worlds or simply a glimpse into
the power of the greater will the elden
beast itself seems to house stars and
space in its gelatinous flesh but its
core is made of a skeletal nervous
system of gold tendrils almost like
roots
it has arms but with its fin-like wings
moves like a primordial fish or slug
early in the road of terrestrial
evolution its long neck capsizes in a
head with a seemingly prominent star
maybe the area in space from which it
originally came
the gold and purple give the beast a
regal tone which is odd for something
that looks so vehemently alien its
soundtrack with heavenly choruses and
harp-like strums adds to this lordly
theme
the elden beast makes use of a number of
attacks that deal holy damage and it
also holds resistance against such kind
of damage too it is set up to be the
earthly head or anchor of the religion
of golden order but its form never
ceases to remind us that it is alien it
creates a juxtaposition with a foreign
alien as head of such an earthly or
lands between religion faith and system
of belief
in this way the themes of the elden
beasts stand out to us and i have no
doubt that this is what from software
intended with its design in these ways
it succeeds
but at the same time this sudden
onslaught of otherness the stark alien
form that we have not been prepared for
in the slightest leaves i think a
feeling of confusion and a thematic
break in what is the game's ultimate
fight
despite its centrality to the order and
the world of the lands between we know
essentially nothing of the elden beast
before the fight
most players will not have even been
aware of its existence in any capacity
before they defeat ratagan this is not
the case for radagon himself for he is
referenced numerous times in game
especially through his connections to
other people and aspects of the world
america gets a smaller showing but we
learn of her before the fight as well
from statues and dialogue from melina
while for many of the bosses in the game
we learn the pivotal aspects of their
stories after our fights with them we
generally come into their battles with
some knowledge and some lead up even if
it's just their world zone this lets us
more readily appreciate their fights and
the context around them it gives each
fight that aspect of story and of the
broader picture
the elden beast comes out of left field
because the lead-up is not to it but to
ratagon and merica even the zone we
fight the elden beast in is not prefaced
by a respective area it is some magical
transformation of or teleportation from
the broken stone at the center of the
earth tree
it does create a novel spectacle for the
fight but it's something we come to with
absolutely no context from software
obviously likes mystery and it's part of
their style of storytelling but the
complete lack of foreshadowing or
introduction or context of the beast
leaves the final fight of the game
disjointed looking at another case from
from's catalog in bloodborne and spoiler
warning for the final boss of bloodborne
we come across a similar godly alien
entity for a final fight but it actually
only appears in a secret ending that the
player has to actively seek out it's not
necessary or the default like the elden
beast
and the being we fight the moon presence
is given much more context by being a
member of the great ones a race of
entities we encounter elsewhere in the
game of bloodborne both in references
impact on the game world and in actual
gameplay whereas we are primed for the
lovecraftian horror fight in bloodborne
the similar otherworldly alien end in
elden ring feels out of place
now the grounds were there for it to
have been prepared for better after all
the elden beast is an integral part of
order and the influence of the greater
will and elden ring in the lands between
we see this through the similarities
found between the elden beast and other
creatures of old power in the game the
yellow flame that constitutes some of
the elden beast's attacks seemed to be
the same kind of fire as we find
fighting with lord placidus
and against the ulcerated tree spirits
both of these creatures are closely
connected with old power in the lands
between especially the power of the
earth tree and of previous cycles of
elden lordship as we read from his
remembrance that placidus was once an
elden lord
the elden beast also seems to use an
attack similar to elden stars which
beyond just giving us some backstory
about the beast also reads this
legendary incantation is the most
ancient of those that derive from the
erd tree
with what i talked about in my video
about the primordial crucible it is
likely that the earth tree grew upon or
on top of some older great tree or some
other form of the original form of life
in the lands between the crucible here
we learn that in the erd tree's early
stages the first incantation which was
derived from it was elden stars which is
essentially a signature attack of the
elden beast
with these kinds of traces of the beast
and the lands between it would have made
sense to have more instances that show
off this influence even if they're shown
only under the surface
if the elden beast is the incarnation of
order which has been around since
ancient times it would make sense for it
to have left more tracks of its
existence as marks in the world this
could have thematically set up the fight
well as a more ancient and cryptic fight
to follow after ratagon something we
have less of an idea about something
which connects to an older aspect of the
world than ratagon and as such is more
suited for the final fight and something
which we have a bit of a bearing for
still shrouded in mystery to make for a
kind of surprise final fight that still
has the impact of the elden beast fight
but something that we come to as i said
with a bit more of a bearing but with
the lore as it is we can only find any
kind of idea of this with fairly deep
research that almost certainly has to
take place long after our fight thus
diminishing the actual fight experience
since it lacks any of this context the
elden beast is a majestic and
overwhelmingly thematic opponent but and
without marring this video with a
discussion on the gameplay mechanics of
the fight it still stands out as too
disjointed of a final fight from a lower
perspective at least in my opinion it
does the beast itself is interesting and
one of our strongest links to the
ominous outer gods but like them the
loose ends and vague illusions outnumber
the confirmable facts to an overwhelming
degree but unlike the outer gods the
elden beast is actually featured in game
which makes its lack of concrete lore
more frustrating i've tried to say
everything certain there is to say about
the beast and i've digressed into a more
meta discussion of how it fits into the
story but any full explanation of the
beast likely has to include some kind of
similar detour the elden beast proved to
be one of the more fruitless searches of
game lore at least in terms of concrete
facts but was still an intriguing avenue
to learn more about the world and the
game as i continue the search for lore
and answers in eldon ring you can
support the search and channel by
becoming a patron on patreon doing so
helps me devote more time and resources
to these videos plus you get some perks
like seeing video scripts early you can
also subscribe to the channel to keep up
to date with video and community posting
and if there's anything i missed or an
inference that i made that you found
faulty let me know in the comments also
feel free to let me know your thoughts
on the golden alien beast with that
thank you for watching peace